Wall Street reopens this morning after
its worst Christmas Eve losses ever the
Dow Jones Industrials fell six hundred
fifty three points on Monday hitting
their lowest level of the year US stock
values have fallen by one trillion
dollars this month they're on track for
their worst December performance since
the Great Depression
Joseph celui co-founder of feminist
trading is here to help us understand
why the markets are dropping Joe good
morning thanks for having me so we saw
on Sunday that Treasury Secretary Steven
ocean called the largest banks tried to
shore confidence in the US markets and
President Trump
blamed the Fed for the problems what
role has have those two things had in
the drop we've seen I think Monday's
sell-off was certainly related to
minuchin comments because they were they
were not necessary you know you don't
make a call like that in my opinion when
there's not a financial crisis going on
and right now there is not a crisis 2008
was a crisis so making a call looking
for liquidity and asking banks for
liquidity it wasn't necessary and what
it did what has the opposite effect
where people started to wonder is there
something we don't know and that's
always the biggest fear certainly that I
have is there something out there so Joe
do you think that his call to the banks
was a thinly veiled attempt to assure
the public that the banks are strong the
market is okay or do you think there was
some fundamental reason he really wanted
to take their temperature yeah I think
the former I think he was trying to
assure the public I think he was trying
to say you know let's make sure
everything's get the markets back up but
you know what that's not his role in
that situation we're not in a crisis
where you have to call the banks and
look for liquidity like secretary
Paulson did back in 2008 which was a
much different story it's a little bit
odd as a call it's like calling your
parents and st. you have emergency
rations I just want to be sure right and
get that call you're worried right what
are you talking about any thought right
and this is a funny thing about the
market when we do the weather report and
what we say doesn't affect the weather
but when we talk about the economy what
we say does affect the economy now the
market and the economy two different
things right is this drop in the stock
market a bad omen for the broader
economy I don't think so I think
actually just last night there was a
report that retail sales is coming out
five percent higher this year so the
economy is strong and the reason why I
know that is the Federal Reserve is they
know what they're doing okay well this
time I think they do I think Bernanke's
guys it was a different story but they
have raising rates because they see a
strong economy which means and you see a
five
retail number so the markets have built
a lot on the economy but also on
confidence and what we have right now is
a confidence crisis things like you know
questioning the Federal Reserve and the
minuchin Commons those are not helpful
let's talk about low unemployment rising
retail sales you know there's a lot of
Goodings the tax cuts actually a good at
kicking and they've been kicking you and
it's a good thing for the economy
there's strong company earnings are
great still we are right now though in a
government shutdown day four of that the
impact that that may have is what I
don't think I you know we've seen these
I've been around for a long time
unfortunately and we've seen a lot of
temporary shutdowns and for the most
part markets just kind of ignore the
shutdown it's not a big deal for the
markets if it how long does it have to
last for it to have an impact you know
if it goes on for a month or something
like that I think we've seen weeks or
like that and those aren't tend to be a
big deal but you know we're more
concerned about you know the general
economic you know where the unemployment
numbers where the industrial production
all those solid numbers that have been
coming out and they're still good right
let's cut to the chase with our money I
mean if people have a thousand dollars
in the market at the beginning of the
year right now they've got what 850 left
yeah how do they protect what's
remaining at the beginning in a month
actually we're down 15% on the month but
I would say don't panic certainly don't
panic and some you know if you look at
your statements and they're gonna be
lower okay but but at this point if you
see this as the way I see it as a strong
economy and a confidence issue that I
think we'll get through then look at it
as a buying opportunity for asked for
long term investors for instance I have
a 529 from one of my kids I added money
on Friday because I think at this point
we're getting towards a you know we're
not gonna say you wanted to put five
thousand dollars in the market put a
thousand in right now and then work your
way through and let's see where this
thing goes right now don't panic just
lose you're gonna loan me that thousand
dollars we'll talk in the break thank
you very much